Hello and welcome to the Professional
Trading Masterclass video series with me,
Anton Creel, ITPM Managing Partner.
So guys, you've arrived at the PTM video
series. What a video series we have in
store for you.
Whether you're here because you're a
retail trader looking to get to a more
professional standard, or you're actually
an individual who is looking to go into
the industry and literally become a
professional trader, this is where it's
at.
This is by far the most comprehensive
education in trading you will ever get.
So guys, this is what we're going to do.
We're going to get straight into it.
We're going to introduce you to three
major concepts straight away.
We're going to be looking at the framework
of the Professional Trading Masterclass
video series and the framework that we're
going to use throughout the video series.
And the three main areas we're going to
introduce you to straight away are the
competency hierarchy, time horizon and
volatility, and the pro trader systematic
framework.
So guys, we will learn those first and
then we're going to look at the most
important thing, and this is going to take
up the bulk of the PTM video series.
We're going to take up the first and then
we're going to take up the first and then
we're going to take up the first.
We're going to take up the first and then
we're going to take up the first and then
we're going to take up the first.
fundamentally driven trade ideas. This
makes up the vast majority of what we do
and it makes up a
huge amount of the Professional Trading
Masterclass. We are rooted in our
fundamentals in both
quantitative and qualitative processes and
this is what we call the discovery and
evidence phase.
It's a combination of both top-down
macroeconomic processes and bottom-up
company level or stock
fundamentals. Next, we move on to trade
timing. How we time our fundamentally
driven trade ideas. This
is in the minority of our process. We use
technical analysis and price action
indicators to time our
fundamentally driven trade ideas. We don't
use technical analysis and price action
indicators
to actually generate the ideas. This is a
major difference between professional
traders and retail
traders. Our trade ideas are rooted in
fundamentals. They are driven by
fundamentals and we use technical
analysis and price action indicators only
to time our trades. Then, much later in
the video series,
we are going to be looking at catalysts.
So, for our time horizon and volatility
optimization, we operate in
the 20 to 60-day time horizon and we do
this in equities, in the stock market. So,
this provides us with a very large
opportunity set. It gives us wholesale
opportunities and a systematic process
within this time horizon and within
equities. This mandate gives us
consistency, which is the holy grail for
traders. We want to get consistent,
outsized
returns. So, our trade ideas are
fundamentally driven trade ideas that are
timed well. We want to be operating within
within that 20 to 60-day time horizon. We
are not investors. We are traders and we
require catalysts for a stock to actually
move within that time horizon.
So, there'll be much more on this way
later in the video series. In the
meantime, we have a lot of work to do on
the trade idea
generation process. After that, we have
what we call in the trade, the whole
process, the whole systematic professional
trader
process, we have trade structuring. So,
what we're going to do in the PTM video
series is actually assume that we're only
going to
have long and short stock positions. The
PTM video series is not an options trading
program. For trade structuring, if you
want
to learn how to structure trades using
options, you have to take the professional
options trading masterclass, okay, the
POTM video series.
Learning how to trade options and how to
structure your trade ideas using options
is an entire class in itself. It can't be
done in the PTM video
video series, okay. Now, next step of the
whole professional trader systematic
framework is risk management.
And this splits up into two areas. We have
preemptive risk management and we have
reactive risk management. So, preemptive
risk
management will be taught in the PTM video
series. However, there's an issue here
with risk management. Unfortunately,
reactive risk
risk management simply cannot be taught in
a video series. Why? Because reactive risk
management involves
actually having a position. And when
you've got a live position, knowing what
to do at any one moment
You've got a live position. You've got a
live position in time in a specific
situation that's specific to a particular
stock.
Unfortunately, retail traders, it's a bad
habit. Retail traders do always look for
rule books and checklists for everything
to do
in every specific situation. This is not
how it works. Okay. So, unfortunately,
reactive risk management, you have to
actually go to the next stage to learn
reactive risk management.
Reactive risk management. It can only be
taught with live positions. And at ITPM,
this can only really be taught
on a trader mentoring program. So, we will
cover preemptive risk management, which is
all the preemptive steps that you can take
before you actually have positions when
building a portfolio. So, the best
practices of preemptive risk management.
Next up in the whole pro trader systematic
process is our trader metrics. How do you
actually measure your performance
as a trader? We're going to show you how
to calculate a track record in a
professional trader way.
It's not just about making money for
professional traders. Of course, that's a
large part of it. It's also about how you
make your money.
Also, in this video, we're going to
introduce you to the ITPM principles, the
four ITPM principles, which we're going to
be utilizing all the way through the video
series.
These are self sustainability, work ethic,
free information, and working smart and
not hard.
So, guys, we're going to get into this
video now, the framework. The whole PTM
video series, there's many parts to it,
many major parts to it.
But the first two major parts of the PTM
video series, we're going to be covering
the pro trader systematic process,
which involves top down and bottom up
fundamentally driven trade idea
generation.
But first, let's cover the framework that
we're going to be using in more detail so
you understand how professional traders go
about things.
This will form the basis of everything we
do going forward in the video series.
So, guys, let's get stuck into it.
Okay, everybody, welcome to the computer
screen and welcome to the Professional
Trading Masterclass video series.
Let's get started. We've got a hell of a
lot to get through. It's a huge, huge body
of work.
And there's a lot of stuff to learn. So
let's start video one, the framework.
Let's start with a little background.
Let's get some context about ITPM, the
Professional Trading Masterclass.
Let's try and understand the bigger
picture here. Okay, so the Professional
Trading Masterclass,
the first version of PTM 1.0 was launched
in May 2013, and it was available from May
2013 to May 2020.
This video series is the second version,
the Professional Trading Masterclass 2.0,
which has replaced the PTM 1.0 in May
2020, and launched in October, November
2021, okay?
Now, in terms of content for the PTM 2.0,
the PTM 2.0, it's not simply an updated
version of the PTM 1.0,
with some, say, more recent examples. It's
a total overhaul of the video series, and
roughly,
it's about two and a half times more
educational content to help retail traders
globally get even
better than they were before. What we've
included in this video series, the updated
version,
is everything that we've learnt as
professional traders by interacting with
retail traders over
the last seven years. And that,
essentially, is a big attempt to improve
the PTM video series even more.
Now, going way back to May 2013, when we
launched the first version of the PTM
video series, the trading
education industry globally was a total
mess, and to a large extent, it still is.
When the first version of the PTM was
launched, and the ITPM really came into
global existence,
we essentially set a new standard by
raising the bar massively in the trading
education industry.
And since then, guys, we've really helped
literally thousands of retail traders to
become profitable
globally through the original PTM video
series and our 12-week trader mentoring
programs.
Now, also, we have our YouTube content,
our YouTube channel, and that's been
online,
up and running since 2013 as well. And
that hasn't just helped thousands of
retail traders,
it's helped millions of people globally
change their approach to financial markets
and to trade better.
When the PTM 1.0 version launched, the
original version, when it launched, it set
everything in
motion. What it did is massively raise the
bar and go global. We took ITPM global,
and we literally changed an entire
industry. We changed the industry for the
better. What are we
doing now? Well, we've decided to raise
the bar again with the launch of the PTM
2.0. And we totally aim
to succeed in moving the industry again
into unchartered territory. From now on,
guys,
the PTM 2.0. The PTM 2.0 will be known and
referred to as the PTM, the Professional
Trading Masterclass
video series. Now, in terms of
prerequisite knowledge, what do you need
to know before
starting the PTM video series? Well, you
can come in with a blank slate. That's
totally fine. But most of
you coming here right now, before taking
the PTM, you will have taken the
Introduction to Professional
Level Trading, the IPLT video series. It's
not an absolute necessity to do before you
start the PTM. But
if you haven't completed this program
prior to starting the PTM video series,
it's definitely
advisable that you do. Why? Because you'll
get a far better understanding of the
concepts,
resources and teachings of the PTM video
series if you do that first.
Now, if you're coming here and you have
completed it, the IPLT video series,
congratulations. You've
definitely made a giant leap forward in
your trading education. There's definitely
not many retail
traders on the planet that have acquired
the knowledge that you have and the
understanding of
financial markets that you've now got. You
are already in the minority of retail
traders,
the significant minority of retail
traders. And as we go through the PTM
video series,
you're just going to get better and better
and better. But for those who haven't
taken the IPLT video
series, and also for those who have, let's
just have a quick recap on the key
teachings and key knowledge
of the IPLT video series before we plow
ahead into the PTM. Okay, so what did we
cover in the IPLT video
series? What did we conclude? Well, we
found that the approach to financial
markets taken by pro traders
is totally misunderstood by retail traders
for multiple reasons. Okay. Secondly,
retail traders are
kept what we call unconsciously
incompetent by the market players that
have inherent conflict of
interest. Okay. Who are those people?
Retail brokers and charlatan trading
educators.
Quite frankly, and this really just sums
up the whole industry. There is a whole
industry,
the entire industry, the entire industry
is built around keeping millions of retail
traders incompetent.
Third, what else did we learn? In
emulating the professional trader
approach,
we learnt in the IPLT video series that we
have to attempt to emulate the function of
hedge fund managers
or the old investment bank proprietary
trading function, but within the bounds of
the retail trading industry
infrastructure and the parameters of
volatility that are set by the market.
Okay. On volatility,
what did we learn? Well, volatility is
both risk and opportunity, which means
it's everything to a
trader. Okay. Volatility is the most
important thing for a trader. We have to
understand the methods of
how to calculate volatility properly. And
we did that in the IPLT video series by
calculating distribution of
returns, average true range percentage and
implied volatility. Those are the methods
and we calculated
it in the same way that professional
traders do it in order to understand its
implications. Why? Because
these are the methods that professional
traders use. Okay. Once we know how to
calculate and understand the
implications of volatility, we have to
know how to exploit it in the same way
that professional traders do.
And from the lessons of volatility, we
learn how to exploit it because we learn
the areas that are
the most consistent and the most
profitable. Okay. So we end up with
concluding that building long,
short one to three months equity and
equity options portfolio for absolute
return is the best area of the
financial markets. So for students who
took the IPLT video series, this is
genuinely a recap. But for those who
haven't taken the IPLT video series, and
I've come straight to the PTM video
series, we definitely advise and
encourage you to encourage you to do the
IPLT first. If you haven't, it will put
into context everything
in the PTM video series. And what it
really does is it shows you and puts into
context why we actually
teach what we're teaching in the PTM video
series. So if you're actually going
through the PTM video series,
and you keep asking yourself the question,
you know, why am I learning this stuff?
Why is this important? Well,
the IPLT video series puts that into
context. Now, we also learned in the IPLT
video series,
how to apply the competency hierarchy. And
for those of you that are new, the
competency hierarchy can be
applied to any learning endeavor, whether
it's, for example, learning a new
language, or perhaps learning a
new skill, like driving, or even, for
example, learning a new profession. So for
example, becoming a chef,
becoming a plumber, an electrician, even
becoming an entrepreneur, and even
becoming a trader. Okay,
so we have four levels to the competency
hierarchy, unconscious incompetence,
conscious incompetence,
and unconscious competence. So in the four
areas, we split up into two big areas, we
have incompetence,
and we have competence. Okay. And if you
look on the right hand side, you look
right at the bottom at
unconscious incompetence. In any setting,
learning any new skill or endeavor.
Unconscious incompetence
basically means you've got no clue what
you're doing, but you think you do. And
this is an area
that's full of delusion, denial, and lies.
In the context of the retail trading
industry, that's where
retail traders exist. Okay. So
professional traders exist at the top of
the trading industry, and retail
traders exist at the bottom. Okay. Let's
climb up the competency hierarchy. What's
the next level? Well,
conscious incompetence. We're still in the
realms of incompetence, but the person now
has the right
information. They know that they're doing
it wrong. They have the right information,
and that information
is going to enable them to learn and
potentially apply the skill set. Okay. But
they're still incompetent,
but they're climbing the hierarchy because
they're now conscious. Okay. In the retail
trading context,
okay, this means that you've learned that
all the things that you used to do don't
work. Okay. And
the reasons for that, and you're starting
to climb the hierarchy. You've started to
become conscious. Okay.
That is now you getting your hands on the
right information. Okay. And this is
basically the IPLT video series,
and the PTM video series, and subsequent
video series at ITPM. Next in the
hierarchy
is conscious competence. And this is where
people sit in endeavors and skill sets
that they're learning
when they actually know how to do it
right. And they're doing it in the real
world and practicing
it, doing it over and over again. They're
implementing the knowledge that they've
learned.
Okay. In the trading context, this is when
you move from theory to implementation.
This is where you
take what you've learned in theory, and
you start to apply it and implement with
real money. Okay. And again,
this can't be done with a demonstration
money, guys. This can't be done in demo
accounts. Okay.
Trading and becoming competent at trading.
It has to be done with real money. It
can't be done with fake
money. Okay. It can't be done in a
spreadsheet. It has to be done with real
money. So this is you over a
period of time implementing the right
knowledge and doing it with real money.
Okay. And then we come to
the level of unconscious competence. What
does that mean? Well, it means you've been
doing it for a good
amount of time. You have a statistically
significant amount of trades that you've
done. You have the
metrics that prove that you are competent
and you're now doing it on repeat and
you're not thinking about
it too much. So in the trading context,
this would mean that you're essentially a
professional trader
level. Now, of course, professional
traders are regulated by regulators.
They've passed their
professional exams and they're trading
with either investor money or if they're
trading at banks with
shareholder money. The skill set itself
doesn't mean you are regulated. You can
still learn all of
the same skills and apply it in a retail
trading infrastructure. But if you are
unconsciously competent,
where you are essentially taking the right
information, you've traded over a period
of
time where you've got a statistically
significant amount of trades and you've
got the trader metrics
and you're now doing it on repeat. You're
not thinking about it too much and you're
just getting the
numbers over and over again. What does
that mean? Well, it just means you're the
level of a professional
trader. It means you're good enough. Okay.
Now, where do you institute traders?
Well, institute traders sit in between
conscious competence and unconscious
competence. Institute
traders are competent and they've either
been doing it for a while and they're
doing it on repeat
and they are essentially professional
traders but operating within the retail
trading infrastructure.
They are professional trading standard but
they're not registered or regulated as
professional traders.
Or they're sitting within the ITPM
infrastructure. They're trading. They're
new to it. They're going up
the competency hierarchy. Or maybe they've
been there for a while and they're stuck
around conscious
competence. And these guys, they may need
mentoring programs because something's
going wrong. They need to
need to have a pro trader on their
shoulder to fix their problems to get them
into unconscious competence.
So institute traders kind of sit between
the two. They're either in one or the
other.
But for most people coming here now,
you're either going to be, unfortunately,
at the level of unconscious
incompetence or conscious incompetence. If
you've taken the IPLT video series,
you've definitely started to climb out of
unconscious incompetence. That information
should absolutely
awaken you to the fact that everything
you've been doing before is wrong. And now
you're getting the
right information. So you should be
sitting on the fringes of the two. So
either just climbing out of
unconscious incompetence, or sitting
somewhere in conscious incompetence. The
PTM video series is the
right information. The IPLT video series
is the right information. If you complete
the PTM video series,
your next step is climbing out of
conscious incompetence into conscious
competence by actually
implementing the information. But let's go
through a textbook guide of what the
competency hierarchy
looks like in the trading context. What do
retail traders have to do in order to
become long-term,
consistently profitable traders? Because
in the IPLT video series, we learned that
if we're going to emulate
professional traders, we absolutely have
to do what they do. And what they do is
they are consistently
profitable over a long period of time. So
what do retail traders have to do in order
to get consistent
profitability? Well, retail traders, the
vast, vast, vast majority, and we're
talking 97%, 98%, 99% of
retail traders will forever be sitting at
the level of unconscious incompetence. How
do you get out of that
level? Well, you've got to drop your old
ideas. You cannot even begin to climb the
competency hierarchy
unless you recognize that the old ideas
you had do not work. Of course, you may
have experienced some fleeting successes.
But overall, you're going to lose over
many trades over a long period of time.
That's because you're not taking an
approach that's sustainable, that allows
you to get consistency. So the actual
professional approach, the approach that
professional traders take.
So the actual professional traders take.
If you climb out of unconscious
incompetence, and you realize that you're
in conscious incompetence, okay, you are
actually learning the pro-trader
systematic processes,
you know, you now understand that
sustainability in trading means consistent
returns,
which can only be achieved through a
robust and repeatable systematic process.
You know, you have to learn the theory of
how professional traders select their
trade ideas, time their trades, structure
their trades, and build portfolios,
and build portfolios, and manage risk,
both preemptively and reactively. You
understand that you have to learn it, and
you acquire this information. Then and
only then,
can you move on to conscious competence.
So you become conscious and you start to
become competent.
And how do you start to become genuinely
competent at trading? Well, you trade with
real money, you implement the processes,
the theory that you've learned. You have
to properly commit to the process that
you've learned and implement the processes
in a live trading account,
a live trading account with real dollars.
Demo accounts do not count. You have to
achieve reasonable returns over a number
of trades over a period of time. And at
this stage, if you do have difficulty over
a time period, bridging that gap between
theory and implementation, you have to
seek professional mentoring. Otherwise,
you're just not going to be able to jump
to the level of unconscious competence.
And at this stage, when you are working on
your weekly schedule, this endeavor, this
skill set, it has to be repeatable and
sustainable. The hours that you put in,
the hours that you commit, and the quality
of work that you output, it has to be
repeatable and sustainable. That is also
how you become consciously competent.
So you have to commit to the process,
implement with real money, and it has to
fit into your life seamlessly.
When you've got those things and you've
done it over a period of time, that's when
you start to move to unconscious
competence. This is when you are on
autopilot mode. You're not just
implementing profitably and doing it
consistently. You're now doing it without
thinking about it too much. It's not
stressful. It comes naturally. Okay. What
happens?
the management of your trading account and
the growth of your account and the weekly
processes
that you adhere to regularly become
natural. You're generating high quality
trade ideas
on a weekly basis. You completely know how
to build and manage your portfolio
successfully
and you do it naturally and with ease. You
also know what to do when things go right.
You know what actions to take when things
go wrong and you're taking all outcomes in
your stride
in a very low stress environment. You're
essentially the same standard as a
professional
trader, but you're existing as retail.
Okay, so now that we've got some context,
we're going to move into the framework
now. What is the whole point of ITPM? What
is the
whole point of our programs? What are we
trying to do here? What is the point of
the IPLT
video series, the PTM, the POTM and the
PFTM video series? What are we trying to
achieve?
What's the objective? Well, ITPM, we're
here to provide a framework that allows
retail traders
to emulate consistently profitable
professional traders so you can benefit
from the same approach.
We're aiming to make retail traders
consistently profitable through a
framework, but the framework
has to allow retail traders to utilize the
same approach that's taken by consistently
profitable
professional traders within their own
retail brokerage accounts. Okay? There's
no point in
learning the theory if you can't implement
and do it with real money. Okay? So we're
trying to make this
real. It has to be implementable by retail
traders in the retail trading
infrastructure. The framework
itself has to allow retail traders to
implement the process from the framework
on a weekly basis and
realistically how they can fit this
endeavor into their normal everyday lives.
So your first step,
once you've actually admitted to yourself,
the wrongs that you've been involved in,
the first step is to
learn the theory. The good news,
obviously, is that you're here already,
which means you're on your
way. You're climbing out of unconscious
incompetence and you're sitting nicely in
conscious incompetence.
ITPM can take you all the way. However,
the video series that we have, the IPLT
plus the PTM plus the POTM
and the PFTM of video programs can only
get you to the door of conscious
competence. You have to step over
the line yourself into unconscious
competence. Okay? Or if you can't do that,
your option is to get a boost from
a trader mentoring program with one of the
professional traders at ITPM. But if you
think about the hierarchy
and you think about our online programs,
for you to get out of conscious
incompetence into conscious competence,
that requires some practical things,
setting up a trading account, depositing
money in the account, generating
trade ideas, putting trades on,
structuring the trades, and building a
portfolio. And doing that over a period
of time, over a number of trades, that
makes it statistically significant. Okay?
To get out of conscious incompetence,
to move into conscious competence, what's
required? Well, you're going to have to
complete the online programs,
the IPLT, the PTM, and the POTM as an
absolute minimum. Okay? And then you're
going to become competent. That's when you
move into competency. And you're doing it
for real, with real money. Okay? You've
got the right information, and now you're
doing it with real money.
And now you're doing it with real money.
You're conscious. To get to the next
level, to unconscious competence, it takes
a period of time,
quite a long period of time, and a number
of trades to become statistically
significant. So, these are our objectives.
Okay?
This is what we're setting out to achieve,
to get as many retail traders as possible,
to emulate consistently profitable
professional traders, to benefit from the
same approach, and using the framework and
processes on a weekly basis, and
realistically fitting that into their
normal everyday lives, and getting you up
the competency hierarchy, right to the top
of unconscious competence.
So, this is the objective, and these are
the objectives of ITPM. Okay?
So, the framework itself, how do we
actually go about achieving this? Well, we
are traders. We are not investors. What
you are looking at here is a chart of time
horizon and financial markets volatility.
If you look at the chart and you look at
the number of days across the top, where
we start on the left-hand side with one
day, five days, 20 days, 60 days, and then
we go all the way out to 120 days, 250
days, which is one financial year for
trading, because there's 250 trading days
in a year.
750 trading days, three years, and 1,250
trading days, five years. Okay?
So, we're looking at trading days in terms
of our time horizon. And traders exist on
the left-hand side. The longer we extend
our time horizon, the more we become
investors. Okay?
Now, this is where the problem lies for
retail traders, because retail traders
always mix up trading and investing. The
time horizon constitutes what you actually
are. It defines what you are. Okay?
So, retail traders, because they don't
really know the difference between trading
and investing. What do they end up doing?
They end up doing a mix of both, whether
that's in the same account or in multiple
accounts. As their overall strategy, what
retail traders tend to do is they either
exist all the way on the left. Okay?
Or all the way on the right as retail
investors. So, it's quite funny. You know,
when we have our applications for
mentoring programs, we actually ask people
what books on trading they've read as one
of the questions.
And most people, the vast, vast majority,
most retail traders, when they apply, when
they're filling out that question, they're
telling us what they've read and all the
books that they have read are to do with
either day trading or it's to do with very
long-term investing, either income or
value investing. Okay?
And there's nothing in between. So, retail
traders genuinely don't understand out
there in the big world that there's an
entire world that's in the middle.
There's an entire world that's between the
classic time horizon of trading, which is
very short-term, and long-term investing.
And it's called long-short portfolio
management. Okay?
So, the problem that retail traders have
is that they're either one or the other,
very short-term traders or very long-term
investors. They don't know anything in
between. So, what ends up happening?
When retail traders are trading, they're
trading one to five days, most of the time
as day traders. What are they doing if
they're trading very short-term,
especially as day traders? They're
competing with algos.
They're competing with software that can
do tens of thousands of trades in a
second, and they're trying to compete
against them for returns. It's not even
possible anymore, guys.
It used to be 20 years ago, maybe up to 15
years ago. It isn't anymore. Okay? So,
this is a zero-sum game. We prove that in
the IPLT video series.
Retail traders become retail investors.
They go all the way to the other side.
What are they doing? They're reading books
on income and value investing, which
haven't worked for decades.
And they're buying cheap stocks in the
hope that in the next three to five years,
they're going to turn around. It's a hope
strategy. And guess what? They have to sit
for three to five years to find out if
they're going to be right or wrong.
That isn't what a trader is, guys. That
isn't what a trader is. Traders are not
investors. Okay? Where do professional
traders actually sit? Okay? Well,
professional traders, the vast majority,
are sitting between the 20- and 60-day
time horizon.
So, we are 20 to 60-day long-short
portfolio managers. Okay? That's what
modern traders are. When we go into
positions, we are going into them with the
aim of making money in the next 20 to 60
trading days. Okay?
And we know that if we keep a position on
beyond 60 days, slowly but surely, the
position starts to become an investment.
And that is the cardinal sin in trading.
When a trade becomes an investment because
you haven't taken off the position. Okay?
We want things to happen in the 20 to
60-day time horizon, where we have the
consistent volatility, where we have the
volatility sweet spot. The longer we keep
on a trade beyond 60 days, the more it
becomes an investment. Now, there's a gray
area between 60 and 120 days, where the
gray area trades start to become
investments.
Beyond 120 days.
Beyond 120 days, a position is absolutely,
at this stage, an investment. Okay? So,
you've had a position on for six months or
more. It absolutely is an investment. In
between 60 and 120 days, it's slowly
becoming an investment.
So, more thing from a trade into an
investment. So, we do have this gray area,
but the vast majority of times,
professional traders are trading in the 20
to 60-day time horizon. If anything's on
for more than 60 days, it's highly, highly
questionable.
So, if anything's on for less than 60
days, that person is probably falling into
bad habits and is becoming slowly an
investor. Okay? We don't want that. We are
not investors. We are traders.
So, in the IPLT video series, when we
looked at volatility, what does it mean
for longshore portfolio managers who exist
in this time horizon? Well, it's the area
of the market that provides wholesale
opportunities and wholesale opportunities
that have the volatility that enables us
to harvest continuous, consistent,
expected return. Okay?
So, that's why we exist in this area.
Okay? That's why we exist in this area.
What happens when volatility moves? Well,
it's adaptable. The process and the
framework is adaptable. Okay? When
volatility goes up, we become, we move
from being portfolio managers and we slide
down the time horizon and we become more
short-term traders.
When volatility declines. When volatility
declines, we slide up the time horizon and
we become more portfolio managers and we
trade and we build long-short portfolios.
Okay? So, it's adaptable. The framework is
adaptable to our time horizon and
volatility.
So, the vast majority of times around 80%
of time, possibly up to 90, we are
existing in the 20 to 60 day time horizon.
Now, the beauty of what we teach here at
ITPM and the beauty of this approach is
that we are existing in the volatility
sweet spot. And therefore, we're learning
in the volatility sweet spot. What does
that mean? Well, if you're in the 20 to 60
day time horizon,
you are learning in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon, you are learning in the majority
about fundamentals. Our trade ideas are
fundamentally driven and we use technicals
and price action for timing only. Okay?
So, what are we doing? We are learning the
best disciplines of fundamentals and the
best disciplines of technicals and price
action. Okay? So, we're learning the best
disciplines of investing and the best
disciplines of trading.
Now, what does that mean in the bigger
picture? Well, from a learning
perspective, this is the best area to
learn to climb up the competency
hierarchy. Why? Because if you learn the
best areas of fundamentals, and you decide
later in your career, you want to become
more of an investor, well, you will slide
up the time horizon. And the other stuff
that you've learned here,
what you've learned here will help you
become a better investor, because you'll
have learned the fundamentals, but you
won't be bad at timing your investing,
your investments. Okay? Because you've
learned all of the other stuff. You've
learned the best disciplines of trading as
well. Okay? And what happens if volatility
increases? Well, if volatility increases,
and or you want to become more of a trader
later in your career, of course, you can
you can slide down the time horizon to
shorter term trading, and you will become
a better, sharper end trader, because
you've not only learned the best of
trading content, you've not only existed
as a trader, you've also existed building
long short portfolios, and your trade
ideas being driven by fundamentals. So, it
will sharpen your trading. You will become
more of a trader. You will become a
better, sharper end trader. You will
become a better, sharper end trader,
because you've not only learned the best
of trading content. You've not only
existed as a trader, you've also existed
building long short portfolios,
long short portfolios, and your trade
ideas being driven by fundamentals. So, it
will sharpen your trading, you'll become a
better trader. Long short portfolio
management, in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon, is not just the volatility sweet
spot, it is also the learning sweet spot
for retail traders, and in fact, all
traders.
So, in terms of the framework that we're
going to be teaching you here, in the PTM
video series, we are going to be teaching
you how to trade in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon. How to build long short equity
portfolios in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon. And we have a process for
building the portfolio. We have a process
that we go through.
We have a process that we go through to
build the portfolio, and to trade the
portfolio, okay, in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon. And we can split this entire
process up into theory and implementation.
Let's start with theory. This is the vast
majority of what you'll be learning, okay,
in the PTM video series. We come up with
trade ideas, okay.
We come up with trade ideas on repeat,
okay. It's the most important thing you
will do, the most important thing you will
learn. And we learned this in the PTM
video series, okay.
The trade idea generation process is
rooted in fundamentals. Our trade ideas
are fundamentally driven, okay. And the
trade idea generation process is split up
into two main parts. The quantitative
process and the qualitative process. We
will cover this in the PTM video series,
okay.
Next up is timing.
Once you've come up with a trade idea and
you believe that it's a trade idea that
you wanted to put into the portfolio.
That's when we have to time our trades.
Okay.
We have to use technicals and price action
to essentially time our trade ideas.
Now, what's the percentage split in terms
of information and efforts that we put in
when we're doing a trade idea?
When we end up with a position, what
drives it the most? Fundamentals or
timing? Absolutely fundamentals.
This is 80% to 90% of everything we do in
the trade idea generation process, okay.
If you've been told in the past, this is
80% to 90% of everything we do in the
trade idea generation process, okay.
If you've been told in the past, this is
80% of everything that we do in the trade
idea generation process, okay.
If you've been told in the past, what's
the percentage split in terms of
information and efforts that we put in
when we end up with a position, what
drives it the most?
Fundamentals or timing? Absolutely
fundamentals.
This is 80% to 90% of everything we do in
the trade idea generation process, okay.
You've been told in the past that
technicals and price action are the
methods for generating trade ideas.
Unfortunately, you've been taught by a
person who has never been a professional
trader.
Professional traders absolutely in their
overall systematic process have the
majority of their work done in
fundamentals.
Their trade ideas in the majority are
fundamentally driven.
Technicals and price action are tools that
are only used to time fundamentally driven
trade ideas.
We do not under any circumstances use
technicals and price action indicators to
generate a trade idea.
And then in the future, use fundamentals
to justify why a position went right or
wrong.
That's for amateurs. That's for idiots.
Okay.
That's for unconscious retail traders.
So professional traders, we are 80% to 90%
fundamentally driven.
And we are 10% to 20% technical and price
action driven.
But the technicals and price action are
not generating the idea.
The idea is fundamentally driven.
And then we use technical and price action
indicators and tools to help us to time
the trade better.
Okay.
Now, this is all theory because it's a lot
of research.
It's work.
You're doing research to generate the
trade ideas.
Okay.
That's actual desk time.
And that's work that you're doing research
that you're doing to generate trade ideas.
That's the vast majority of what you'll
do.
Okay.
Next up is trade structures.
Why?
Because we're looking at catalysts.
Before we have a position, we need to look
at catalysts and decide what trade
structure we're going to have.
And that isn't necessarily just going long
or short a stock.
We can utilize options.
And more often than not, there will be
option structures that are more optimal
than being long or short a stock.
Given the catalysts that are coming up in
the next 20 to 60 days.
So when we're implementing, which is the
big area over here, where we're now
trading with real money.
So implementing everything on the right
hand side.
When we're implementing, we're choosing
our trade structures around the catalysts
that we forecast.
Now, of course, once you end up with a
position, there is risk management.
Okay.
And risk management splits up into two
areas.
Preventative risk management and reactive
risk management.
We will come onto this much later in the
video series.
But just understand and appreciate the
basic framework for now.
The key message to take away here is that
in the trade idea generation process,
which is the most important part.
Okay.
The vast majority of the work we do is
fundamentally driven.
Our trade ideas are fundamentally driven.
But there is a bigger overall definition
of what constitutes a trade idea.
So what are the differences between, for
example, a day trade or a short term
trade, an investment and an actual long
short portfolio manager trade idea?
Okay.
Well, let's have a look at day trades
first.
What are you doing when you generate a
trade idea, when you're trading in the
time horizon of one day, where you're
going to come in in the morning, you're
going to be flat.
And when you leave at the end of the day,
when the market closes, you're going to be
flat as well.
You only have positions in the one day
timeframe.
Well, you're going to be basically
scalping what we call order flow.
So orders that are in the markets that are
moving stocks up and down in very short
windows of time.
And you're going to be trading on
candlestick charts, which are minute to
minute.
And you're going to be using technical
analysis and price action indicators a
hundred percent of the time.
There's no fundamentals in the one day
time horizon.
So it's just going to be trading on very
short term indicators and very short term
news flow.
So basically a lot of noise and hunches.
Okay.
What about an investment?
Well, we've mentioned this earlier.
It's going to be three to five years based
on fundamentals.
Of course, it can be growth as well as
value, but there's a problem.
You have to sit around and wait for three
to five years to find out if you're going
to be right or wrong.
Now, what about something that's prevalent
in the market from retail traders in
recent years?
The you only live once retail trades.
Those can be both short term positions.
So one day to one week.
And they can also be investments where
you're basically fully subverted to a
narrative.
That's an investment is going to go up by
thousands and thousands and thousands of
percent over a three to five year period
or longer.
And you just keep that trade on as a YOLO
trade as an extremely high percentage of
your account and or net worth.
And you're all in.
You're essentially all in on the position.
So it can be one day to one week or it can
be an investment.
Now, when we compare this to a long short
portfolio manager trade ideas in the one
to three month time horizon.
What's the definition there?
And what's the differences?
Well, the differences are very easy to
spot.
If we look at what it actually is, the
long short portfolio manager in the one to
three month time horizon is utilizing
fundamentals in the vast majority, but
also using technicals and price action.
So we're 80 percent fundamental, 10
percent technical roughly and 10 percent
roughly price action.
But that's not where it ends.
A trade idea, the definition of a trade
idea includes other things.
Okay.
It also includes having catalysts within
the 20 to 60 day time horizon, the one to
three month time horizon.
It also includes coming up with what you
believe to be is the optimal trade
structure in the one to three month
timeframe.
And it also involves risk management, both
preventative risk management and reactive
risk management.
So some sort of plan in terms of risk
management on the trade idea that you're
going to implement prior to having the
position and also a plan to exit, whether
it's going to be a winner or a loser, how
you're going to react when the stock
moves.
Okay.
And also how you're going to react to
certain catalysts if they come out.
So this is what you're going to learn in
the PTM and the POTM video series.
The implementation phase can be either
done by yourself.
Okay.
It can either be done by yourself inside
or outside ITPM.
So, of course, you can complete the PTM
video series.
You can do additional video programs at
ITPM and you can choose not to become an
institute trader.
However, you can choose not to implement
inside the institute infrastructure.
That's fine.
That's totally fine.
Everyone is an individual and everyone has
individual circumstances and choices.
If you do come into the ITPM
infrastructure, you'll be implementing the
program content in real time with real
money.
Okay.
But you can also opt for a 12-week
mentoring program followed by doing it
yourself or you can do a mentoring program
upfront.
That's totally fine.
We're very flexible.
But the implementation phase, you do it
yourself either inside or outside the ITPM
infrastructure.
But essentially, regardless of the
infrastructure that you're operating in,
you will be in the larger context in the
retail trading infrastructure and you're
going to be implementing the trade idea
generation process, which is 80%
fundamental, 20% technical and price
action.
It's going to include catalysts include
trade structuring and risk management.
Every trade idea has to have all of those
elements.
Otherwise, it just simply isn't a trade
idea.
The trade idea generation process.
What about that part where we're looking
at fundamentals?
Let's have a look at that because it's
important to understand the details of the
framework.
Earlier, we looked at fundamentals being
rooted in a quantitative process and a
qualitative process.
It's by far the biggest and most important
part of the overall professional level
trade idea generation process.
It's the discovery phase of the idea.
Okay.
The discovery phase of the trade idea.
And that is a combination of quantitative
and qualitative processes and assessment.
Okay.
We mentioned previously, we are minimum
80% fundamental analysis and maximum 20%
technical analysis and price action when
generating trade ideas.
Okay.
We do not pull up a chart, draw some
meaningless lines on the chart, and then
look for some superficial fundamentals to
justify why we happen to have the long or
short position or using those fundamentals
to explain afterwards why we had a winner
or loser in the portfolio.
So, we begin with a really thorough
top-down analysis of macroeconomics.
And we combine this with a bottom-up
fundamental analysis in order to generate
long and short biases for the overall
stock market, for sectors, and for
individual stock picks.
Now, this, you know, when we're talking in
this language and talking about these
definitions, don't worry about it too
much.
But you're going to learn all of this
stuff later in the video series.
But understanding the basics here of the
framework, we're looking at combining
top-down analysis, top-down analysis, and
bottom-up analysis, so macroeconomics and
microeconomics, to obtain long and short
biases in assets.
Okay.
And those assets are the overall stock
market, equity sectors, so industry
sectors, and individual stocks within
those sectors.
Okay.
We'll come on to this in great detail
across the video series.
So, we're using macroeconomic fundamentals
to obtain a macro view on the stock
market.
And we're using microeconomic fundamentals
to obtain a micro view on stocks and
sectors within the overall stock market.
When we put these two things together,
when we marry the two, it gives us an edge
in that we allocate dollars with
confidence in our ideas and our positions.
We take this approach under the assumption
that we are operating, of course, in the
optimal areas of the stock market to
exploit volatility.
And that was covered in the IPLT video
series.
So, we understand which area of the market
that we need to be in to get consistency
and to get consistency in returns, okay,
to become consistently profitable.
So, we understand the area that we need to
be in within the market, and then we use a
process to generate the ideas and to
generate those consistent returns.
The quantitative process though, guys,
obviously, it comes with a bit of an
expectation of educational understanding,
okay?
The quantitative process, it's mechanical,
It requires a lot of spreadsheet and data
work.
Similar to the IPLT video series, you're
going to have to get yourself up the
curve, okay?
And it takes a while.
It takes a while to learn this stuff and
internalize it, okay?
To get yourself up the curve, you're going
to have to first learn how to obtain and
process data.
It's very important in the world of
financial markets, very important in the
world of trading, to become comfortable
with data and statistics and processes, to
manage the data and processes.
But additionally, you're going to have to
learn how to understand and interpret the
data, okay?
So, it's not just about mechanically doing
it, it's about understanding and
interpreting data.
In the PTM video series, you're going to
be taught all of this spreadsheet work and
how to process everything yourself.
So, you're going to be taught all of the
processes, so you can go away and do
everything for yourself.
You'll also be taught how to understand
those processes and how to interpret the
data properly, okay?
That's very, very important.
Very important skill sets for competent
traders to learn, okay?
This is going to be done with both
macroeconomic and microeconomic data.
So, you'll be able to locate interesting
potential long and short stock ideas for
the rest of your life.
And most importantly, doing it for
yourself, okay?
Now, there is a caveat.
The quantitative process is simply the
first step to generating an actual trade
idea, okay?
You saw earlier that a trade idea is not a
trade idea or can be defined as a trade
idea,
unless it has all the elements that we
covered.
So, when you go through a quantitative
process, please note, we use the word
potential, okay?
At that stage, you don't have a trade
idea.
The next stage you have to go to is the
qualitative assessment.
You also need a timing assessment.
You also need to look at optimal trade
structuring.
And you also need to understand about how
you're going to manage your risk of that
trade.
It's an entire process and an entire plan,
okay?
Everything's going to be fully explained
later in the video series.
Here, I'm just giving you an overview of
the framework itself.
So, you understand every single step and
every single element of the framework and
what constitutes a trade idea.
The next step, qualitative assessment.
Qualitative processes and assessment,
okay?
As part of the overall trade idea
generation process.
So, when we're looking at fundamentals to
generate trade ideas, we do not just stop
at the quantitative phase, okay?
We don't just do quantitative assessments
and then stop and think we have a trade
idea.
We don't, okay?
We don't just use the mechanical processes
utilizing the data in the spreadsheets.
We also engage in a qualitative process to
assess the quality of a company stock
behind the numbers, okay?
What we do in the qualitative process is
we find out what's driving the performance
of the company and its valuation.
Whether it's good or bad.
Just knowing the numbers is not good
enough.
If we're going to have a position in the
stock, long or short, we have to know why
we have a position.
The most important reason we do this is to
have a deep understanding of what is going
on behind the scenes in a stock.
What is driving the valuation?
What is driving the fundamentals of the
stock, okay?
So, imagine you have the position on and
some qualitative information comes out
while you've got the position on.
What's going to happen?
You're going to be able to interpret that
information correctly, okay?
If the trade goes wrong, you will know
what to do with it.
If a trade goes right, you will also know
We're not trading blind.
We understand what's going on beneath the
hood, not just in the spreadsheets and in
the numbers.
We know what's going on qualitatively
beneath the hood, okay?
The qualitative process is an essential
add-on to the quantitative process because
it deepens and furthers our understanding
in a stock and gives us higher conviction
in our positioning.
What does that mean?
Well, our higher conviction in a position
comes from a higher understanding of what
qualitative factors are that are driving a
stock's fundamentals and valuation.
This is what gives us a major edge in the
market, okay?
This is what gives us an edge over other
market participants and it is edge that we
need in order to make superior returns
within the parameters of the market where
we get optimal volatility.
Why?
Because the vast majority of market
participants will never do the work.
They will never dig as deep as we do and
have a deeper understanding of what's
really driving a company and driving
stocks valuation.
Next is timing.
So, we've generated an idea, what we think
is a good idea.
It's got potential.
We've been through the fundamentals.
We've been through the quantitative and
the qualitative processes and we decide we
really want to have this position.
What's next?
Well, it's timing.
It's timing.
We've been through quant and we've been
through qualitative assessment.
However, even at this stage, we've not yet
obtained fully what can be described as a
trade idea.
What we've got at this stage is a bias,
okay?
We've obtained a bias, a long or short
bias on an asset, on a stock.
Now, we have to time the trade.
Once we have our timing and we understand
that it's in play, it's ready to go,
and we have our additional stuff like
trade structuring and our risk management
plan,
that is when we have a trade idea.
So, at this stage, we use technical
analysis, TA, and price action, PA.
We use those indicators to help us time
trades better.
And occasionally, we use those tools for
some risk management practices if it makes
sense to do so.
Now, at this stage, if we conclude that
it's the wrong time to put on a trade, we
wait for a better time.
It's not a trade idea yet, okay?
All we have at this stage is a bias.
If it's the right time to put on the
trade, we think it's the right time to put
on the trade,
we move on to choosing our optimal trade
structure.
So, you can see we're going through the
processes.
And at the timing stage, it might be
rejected as a trade idea because the
timing is not right.
If the timing is right, then we move on to
trade structuring because it passes the
next filter of the definition of a genuine
trade idea.
Now, we do not use technical analysis and
price action indicators to generate ideas.
That is for uneducated retail traders,
brokers, and charlatan trading educators
who are all operating at the level of
unconsciously incompetent, okay?
So, TA and PA is useful, but it has its
place in an overall pro-trader systematic
process.
The place that it has is only to help with
timing and some occasional risk
management, okay?
So, don't put too much weight on technical
analysis and price action indicators.
There's so much weight put on TA and PA by
the unconsciously incompetent.
What it essentially does is it keeps you
there at the level of unconscious
incompetence because it's the blind
leading the blind.
People misuse it.
And there's multiple reasons for that that
are covered in the IPLT video series.
But it is not, TA and PA is not for
generating trade ideas.
It helps us time fundamentally driven
ideas.
Fundamentals give us our bias on an asset,
so a stock.
Fundamentals give us our bias, long or
short, and it gives us a potential trade
idea with edge.
So, technical analysis and price action
indicators help us in timing the trade.
That's all they do, guys, okay?
So, don't put too much weight on it.
It does not generate a trade idea.
Now, if we believe at this stage that we
have our fundamentally driven bias.
We've got our timing.
Things are starting to look good for our
trade idea.
We move on to trade structuring.
Trade structuring is done around
catalysts, okay?
Time horizon and volatility are the two
main constricting parameters in trading.
We, as longshore portfolio managers, are
operating in the one to three month time
horizon.
And we're placing ourselves in that
volatility sweet spot that we covered
earlier.
In the IPLT video series, viewers watching
now, you will have understood that for us
to optimize these opportunities, we
require wholesale opportunities to enable
consistency.
Every position that we take, however, must
also present further opportunity, so
potential volatility above what is already
priced in by the market.
And for that, we absolutely require
catalysts that are going to occur within
the one to three month time horizon while
the position is live, okay?
Now, there's going to be much more on this
later in the PTM video series.
For now, just try to understand the
framework, okay?
Around catalysts, we build trade
structures, okay?
We seek to optimize the trade structure
around the idea within the one to three
month timeframe.
And that is, that can be additional to
just simply going long or shorter stock,
okay?
There's multiple trade structures
utilizing mostly equity options that we
can consider.
And that is mostly covered in the POTM
video series.
One of the biggest mistakes of retail
traders in the stock market is to think in
the following terms.
When you're looking in the stock market,
retail traders think that a good company
automatically equals a good stock and that
automatically equals a good trade idea.
That is a very bad habit and a very bad
way of thinking, okay?
It's just completely wrong.
What usually ends up happening in these
situations?
Well, the stock ends up not even moving
within what can be defined as a trading
time horizon.
And then it ends up becoming an
investment, okay?
We do not operate with this mindset.
We want to make money in the 20 to 60 day
time horizon.
We require catalysts and we require trade
structures that optimize those catalysts
within the time horizon.
This is what constitutes a genuine trade
idea.
A good company does not necessarily equal
a good stock for a trader.
And it does not necessarily equal a good
trade idea.
It's just the wrong way to look at things,
guys.
But retail traders fall into this trap
time and time again.
So again, guys, just to hammer it home
because we need to iron out all of these
bad practices of retail traders, okay?
In the framework, you have to understand
we are not investors.
We are traders.
We do not take positions in stocks and
then sit around waiting for years to find
out if we're going to be right or wrong,
okay?
We require, we need catalysts.
And from those catalysts, we build trade
structures that optimize the payoff within
the one to three month time horizon.
The trade structure that we choose has to
reflect the fundamentals, the timing and
the catalysts that we see occurring in the
next one to three months.
And as I've mentioned, there are multiple
endless potential trade structures that we
can take advantage of to just simply being
long or short a stock.
So in options, for example, option
structures are covered in the POTM video
series.
And when we look at advanced structures,
unfortunately, advanced structures can
only be done on a mentoring program.
In the PTM video series, we're going to be
looking only at long and short stock
portfolios, okay?
So we can't, obviously, in the PTM video
series where we're teaching you the
framework and every element in it, go and
become experts on options as well.
Options trading requires an entire video
series, okay?
But what we will be covering is pre-active
and reactive risk management practices on
stock portfolios.
That's going to be covered in the PTM
video series.
So again, the framework, guys, and what
constitutes a trade idea.
What constitutes a genuine trade idea is
all of the elements.
You need to cover all of this to be good
at generating trade ideas.
All of the elements need to be covered.
Now, when you've been through the entire
trade idea generation process in theory
and in implementation, what's going to
happen?
You're going to put positions on and
you're going to take positions off.
It's really that straightforward.
Positions will be winners, losers, or
coming out flat or around flat.
You're going to have to measure your
performance.
And for that, there's trader metrics and
trader performance, okay?
As traders, of course, we place ourselves
in that volatility sweet spot and we
expose ourselves to an abundance of high
quality trade ideas.
And we're aiming to get consistency.
We're building the one to three month
longshore portfolios.
When we're going through this whole
exercise, we're going to end up placing
many trades over a period of time.
And initially, what you should be worrying
about is your first year, okay?
As traders, we must have feedback on our
performance.
Now, of course, making money is a great
indicator.
Most retail traders don't make money,
okay?
So just going in to the market with the
right information, implementing
successfully is making money, okay?
But we need to get feedback on more.
We need to understand how we're making
money and what our strengths and
weaknesses are so that we can improve
incrementally over time.
You know, coming from unconscious
incompetence into unconscious competence
and then becoming consciously competent,
that takes time.
So, when you're implementing, around one
year is when things start to become
statistically significant.
But if you're just making money coming
from a long period of time where you've
implemented all the wrong stuff, you've
got the wrong information, you've
implemented all the wrong stuff.
So, if you're just making money, that's a
great start.
But we have to understand when we've
booked a number of trades over a year or
so, we have to understand how we're making
money.
And within that data, we're going to
really understand what our strengths and
weaknesses are, okay?
Now, on the flip side, of course, if we're
down and we're losing money, as traders,
we want to understand why as well.
Trading performance and using trader
metrics gives you a comprehensive analysis
of this, okay?
And again, you have to interpret the data.
So, we have a comprehensive analysis of
our trading performance that's provided by
our trader metrics and that measures what
we call our track record.
Our trader track record is the evidence of
our performance as traders.
And not just that, it tells us how we got
the performance.
It's essentially like switching on an
x-ray machine and looking at the anatomy
of a trader.
In the PTM video series, what we're going
to be doing is we'll be showing you all of
the key professional trader metrics to
measure your performance and track record.
And how to actually understand and
interpret the statistics so you can
understand your strengths and weaknesses.
You will be using these resources forever.
You'll be tracking your performance,
tracking your strengths and weaknesses,
how you make money, how you lose money,
interpreting it, understanding it, and
incrementally getting better over time.
So, getting a better understanding of this
overall framework is absolutely essential
as we start the video series.
So, when you move on, you've got the
bigger picture understanding and the
context of why we're doing certain things,
okay?
We're going to go through every single
stage of the process.
But, when we do that, and when you're
working for the rest of your life as a
retail trader operating in the retail
trading infrastructure, you have to level
up your game, okay?
We're going to go through every single
stage of the way.
So, we're going to go through every single
stage.
We're going to go through every single
We're going through every single stage.
stage.
We're going to go through every single
We're going through every single stage.
And we're not going to be telling you when
to buy and sell stocks.
That's for dumb retail traders at the
unconscious, the incompetent level.
As we outlined in the IPLT video series,
there's an entire industry out there,
a whole industry waiting to take advantage
of laziness.
And the retail trader wish fulfillment for
shortcuts and hacks.
We don't do that at ITPM.
We're going to give you the tools, but we
need you to respond.
Okay?
You need to respond with work ethic.
And work ethic is conscientiousness, not
passion, not motivation.
Okay?
Try to eliminate those words from your
vocabulary.
Replace passion and motivation with
conscientiousness.
It's way more important.
But guys, don't be scared of the work.
We're going to take you through all of
these processes.
It's not as hard as you think.
It just requires application and
conscientiousness.
Once you understand it, it's
straightforward.
And over time, your processes will get
quicker the more you practice.
The hard yards in this game are put in
now.
But it does get easier over time.
So just stick at it.
Next up in ITPM principles, free
information.
When you're starting out learning how to
trade, it's important to get your hands
dirty.
Getting your hands dirty in the data to
really understand the nuts and bolts of
financial markets and how to interpret the
data properly.
At this stage, you absolutely do not need
to pay for third-party software and incur
expenses in an attempt to create
shortcuts.
Your interpretation of publicly available
data is way more important than having a
software subscription.
Think about it.
What is the point of paying for software
and data if you don't even know where it
comes from?
You don't even know how to understand and
interpret it.
And you haven't even turned a profit in
your trading account yet.
A software is not going to turn you into a
profitable trader.
Only you can do that.
You need to get, in the beginning, your
hands dirty in the data to truly
understand the nuts and bolts of this
business.
To understand the underpinnings of the
financial markets.
And you need to understand how to
interpret it properly.
No software can replicate those two
endeavors.
Okay?
It's very important at the beginning of
your career to do that.
You know, when we had graduates coming
from university onto the Goldman Sachs
trading desk, we knew that they had all
the resources at their fingertips.
We knew we'd be giving them amazing
software, Bloomberg software, et cetera,
and they would have access to amazing data
sets.
Okay?
But we also knew that they didn't even
know where the data came from, what it
means, and how to interpret it.
So we made them get their hands dirty for
at least the first three months.
Okay?
In building spreadsheets, crunching data,
and understanding all the processes, and
understanding the nuts and bolts of
financial markets.
It's absolutely crucial in the beginning
stages of your development that you learn
how to do that.
We stick to the principle of free
information, we look at publicly available
data sets, and we learn how to process
that data, and get an understanding of the
nuts and bolts of financial markets.
One of the biggest secrets of the
financial education industry is that it's
totally possible to make money first with
free information.
From the data, by getting your hands dirty
in the data, and understanding the
financial markets first.
Why?
Because they all want you to sign up for
recurring revenue products like software.
Okay?
A lot of this stuff gets sold to you as a
shortcut and a hack, and gets sold to you
as a panacea or a solution, okay, to your
problem of not being able to make money.
The software will never give you the
answer, guys.
Okay?
The software will just give you data that
you can get elsewhere, but you can learn
how to get your hands dirty in the data,
and learn how to interpret it properly.
Okay?
You just have to be taught how to do it by
people who know how.
So, professional traders.
Okay?
Then, and only then, are you allowed to
start subscribing to products that give
you a quick answer, or subscribe to
products that save you some time.
Okay?
Then, and only then, are you allowed to go
and spend money on third-party software
and pay for data.
And even then, only if it makes sense to
do so.
So, at the Institute, in the beginning, we
stick to this principle of making money
first.
You open your trading account, you put
money into your account, and you make
money first, implementing what you have
learned in theory.
And when you make money from it, maybe a
small percentage can be spent on softwares
later.
Not now.
Later.
Okay?
So, you start out with no resources prior
to ever paying for anything.
It's a very important principle, because
it has a lot of ramifications.
It means it forces you to get your hands
dirty, forces you to learn financial
markets properly, and it forces you to
understand how to interpret the publicly
available free information.
Okay?
That gives you a fantastic fundamental
crutch for the rest of your career.
So, you may not even ever need to pay for
software.
That's the beauty of it.
So, we stick to this principle, because
it's very important to start off your
career getting your hands dirty from the
free information.
Stick to the principle of making money
first from free information, never paying
for anything, and then if it makes sense
to do so in the future, then perhaps think
about it, if it adds value to your
trading.
Next up, working smart, not hard.
Once you've actually done the hard yards
of learning the theory, and then you move
on to implementation, of course, this
whole endeavor of trading in the same way
that a professional trader does, but in
the retail trading infrastructure as a
retail trader, it has to fit into your
regular weekly life.
Now, earlier, we referred to work ethic,
okay?
And when we did so, we referred to
conscientiousness, not passion or
motivation.
And certainly here, not the amount of
hours you're willing to work per week.
You can work for 50 hours a week on
trading and not make money.
You need to work smart, okay?
You've got to eliminate the vast majority,
the 97% of bullshit and noise in the
market that doesn't fit your objective.
That being consistent profitability.
Very obviously, there is both a minimum
and a maximum amount of hours that you
need to put in per week.
A good trader is a consistently profitable
trader.
And that requires you to show up every
week to put in the minimum hours.
But we have to be realistic.
Retail traders are likely to have full or
part-time jobs.
They're likely to be running small
businesses, for example.
Retail traders can be at college or
university.
So you've got other things that you're
doing in your life.
You've got your family.
You've got hobbies and interests, okay?
There's only so many hours in a week,
okay?
Given your other endeavours and other
considerations.
So you need to also apply a maximum, okay?
When you're starting out, there's a
minimum and a maximum.
The minimum is obvious why you have it.
Because if you're going to build a
portfolio and you're going to trade it, it
takes a certain amount of hours minimum to
do so.
But there's also a maximum that you have
to apply.
There is a diminishing marginal utility to
working over a certain amount of hours per
week on your trading.
Even if you're doing it to the standard of
a professional trader.
And you don't want it to affect other
areas of your life.
Why? Because when you're starting out,
it's not a full-time job.
It's a part-time endeavour.
Essentially, trading, building portfolios
when you start out, is a hobby or an
interest, okay?
Slowly over time, as you make more money,
you can put more time into it, okay?
But your time starts off with a minimum
and maximum.
And you only put more in above the maximum
if it's becoming an extremely profitable
venture, okay?
We're going to show you in the PTM video
series how to optimise your hours and to
work really smart, okay?
So getting the most out of those hours per
week.
No dead time, getting the most out of
those hours and being super efficient,
okay?
Principle number four, work smart, not
hard.
It's extremely important to stick to this
principle going forward.
So starting out in the video series, try
to internalise these principles and try to
internalise all of the main parts of the
framework and the trade idea generation
process and also what constitutes a trade
idea.
So let's add a few more elements to the
ProTrader Systematic Framework for long
short portfolio management in the 20 to 60
day time horizon.
So you'll see under theory and
implementation, we've added a few boxes,
okay?
We've added volatility and opportunity
set.
This comes from the IPLT video series,
okay?
And help you with the overall process,
Under implementation, you'll see that
we've added real money trading.
That comes from you trading by yourself.
So self-trading or on an institute trader
mentoring programme.
Self-trading can be done outside the
institute or it can be done inside the
institute, okay?
But if you're inside the institute and you
believe that you may need help with a
professional trader looking over your
shoulder, one of the guys at ITPM can help
you over a 12-week period in the
implementation phase.
Okay?
Or if you're struggling in the
implementation phase, you can choose to do
a mentoring programme later.
You'll see that we've also added to the
right-hand side after risk management when
positions come off.
So we have the total process on the
left-hand side flowing to the right-hand
side.
Obviously positions go on and then
positions come off, okay?
What have you got when positions come off?
Well, you've got your trader metrics and
your track record.
What is that?
It's your performance as a trader.
And you get that from statistical
significance, probably over one year to 18
months with about 100 to 150 trades,
something like this.
That's when things become statistically
significant and you start really learning
what type of trader you are, what your
strengths and weaknesses are, and whether
you're any good at this, okay?
And adding these boxes in is helpful
because it gives you the context and
understanding of the overall framework
that we're trying to teach at ITPM.
So moving forward into the PTM video
series, we're going to look at every
element, of course, inside the boxes and
the trader metrics, every element inside
the boxes and the trader metrics.
The volatility and opportunity set is the
IPLT video series and real money trading
happens with real money either as an
institute trader or outside the institute
self-trading or as an institute trader on
a mentoring program.
So, we're going to go through all of the
things from left to right, fundamentals,
quantitative and qualitative processes,
timing, trade structuring happens more in
POTM because that's with options, but we
will do long and short positions in the
PTM video series.
So, adding these boxes gives you a better
understanding of the context.
So, guys, let's summarize a systematic
process or framework in general terms.
And I say in general terms because it's
not just guys in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon on the professional side of
trading that utilize systematic processes
and frameworks.
They're utilized by shorter term traders.
They're utilized by investors as well.
So, what is it?
In the broader context, a systematic asset
selection process is just a process in
which a trader or investor goes through a
series of processes in order to find
trades and investments that provide a
higher probability of success when
compared to simple randomness.
Okay.
All professional traders and investors use
a framework to select their positions.
The vast majority of professional traders
out there globally use one that's very
similar to the framework that you're going
to learn in the PTM video series.
Now, the framework presented in the PTM
video series is adaptable to any market.
Okay.
You can tweak it.
It's flexible.
Okay.
It's not rigid.
So, you can take that framework into any
market where you can trade publicly
available assets.
It's a very, very useful tool.
Okay.
Now, at different stages of the framework,
of course, you can choose to add your own
processes, your own inputs that are
additional to what you're learning in the
PTM video series.
It's totally acceptable and we encourage
you to do this.
We obviously can't cover every single
thing that's going to add value to a
trader's life in one video series.
Okay.
If you want to add stuff in to certain
areas of the entire process, the entire
framework, that's completely fine.
It's totally acceptable and we encourage
you to do it.
But a small caveat, it has to be in the
spirit of increasing your odds of making
money.
Okay.
As long as that's the case, then
absolutely feel free to add your own
inputs and processes into the area of the
framework that you think they should be
applied to.
That's totally fine.
Okay.
So that covers the framework, guys.
I hope you've got a better understanding
of what a professional trader systematic
process looks like, what the framework
looks like at ITPM and what we're going to
be teaching you here in the PTM video
series.
Let's go back to the desk and move on to
video number two.
Thank you.